i want to thank everybody for being a
part of my life and i want to let you
know that i have some uh new tour dates
um i am going to be uh los angeles may
7th we added a show there at the will
turn
uh albuquerque
may 18th
midland texas may 19th lubbock
may 20.
dallas texas may 21 that one's almost
sold out
savannah
june 2nd augusta georgia montgomery
alabama columbus georgia june 3rd 4th
and 5th i appreciate all you guys love
and support um tickets are on sale now
at
theovonn.com
t-o-u-r
that's
theovonn.com
tour and um yeah i'm just grateful for
you guys thank you so much
today's guest is returning uh for the
second time um
and he's really
he's a one-of-a-kind impersonator and
comedian and creature
and he is a real unique man i would say
that
if they had a hundred men somewhere he'd
be the only one like him
uh we're happy to have him back
and uh he has his own show on youtube
called the kyle dunnigan show
ladies and gentlemen today's guest mr
kyle dunigan
[Music]
light on me
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dude remember my fight idea we haven't
done yet
what was it were we gonna fight
no
who would win i'm fast
i would win you're stronger but i'm i'm
faster for sure i'm also i can get down
low and come up huge like i get low and
like what do you mean like one of those
like like a uh
like one of those lizards that like does
that big trick yeah i have a very long
torso and i can just suddenly you'll be
like how do you get way down there and
then i'll pop up huge i would be
surprised
i i
you there's two parts of me that wants
you know one that wants to
figure it out a little
when we hugged a little while ago i felt
like i would win enough fight
real what did you just feel soft muscles
on my back or something i mean i don't
know if soft muscles is a real thing bro
is that yeah like wagyu beef oh yeah
yeah yeah i felt that way
yeah i definitely felt a sort of uh
definitely something that had been caged
you know
yes yes well you're wrong okay um i'm
very dense actually really that's a
yeah just genetically a dense muscle
structure have you had your marrow
tested or not
yeah
dense mary have you have you had your
marrow tested yeah man oh that's
miserable huh why'd you have it tested
um i think i was having some chronic
type of thing and so they tested it
but that kind of stuff's miserable
yeah i have this thing called him a liar
i never had it tested do you ever get
punched in the face
yeah can you take a punch or do you sort
of get your bell wrong or you're lost it
hurts but it also depends on how i am
if i'm ready for it um i i think i can
kind of do okay i have no idea like i
might have an iron chin or just paper i
have no idea
and there's only one way to find out you
know you never know until you get
punched what's that
i'm sorry yes
should i get earplug
our idea was we were going to match up
celebs be celebs and do our own
celebrity pay-per-view kind of thing
well you saw that aaron carter's fought
uh lamar odom
i didn't see that did that already
happen it's gonna happen it already
happened let's bring up a clip of that
if we can let's go to the eclipse
um but there's this big money in this
and then me and you we commentate on it
whatever we bring our expertise to the
table
i like it who would be a good match
that's what we're talking about because
comedians like you know they have little
fights kind of like rappers or whatever
you just go you sort of preamble with
the fight and then you sort of announce
they're going to actually physically
fight yeah
and you can just keep it on mute
let's see if we're good at being
commentators as we do this there comes
lamar odom into the ring now he's and oh
and there's aaron carter look at him
he's kind of bouncing oh there's a
height difference it's intense this
reach is just not fair well you see
carter there is nipple high on that
brother
he actually is fighting a man who was in
the hospital uh didn't he have a
concussion he went into some kind of
coma right both these guys have
overdosed jesus
come on
this is not fair
and there's uh oh and they hug at the
end that's like when you hug me he feels
this soft man so obviously they must
have showed the highlight there or
they're not like that
that seems like an awful
fight if that was the highlight lamar
got the nod there um who would be a good
match i think maybe what about machine
gun kelly versus kelly slater
oh that'd be cool to just match names
yeah like that or versus megan kelly oh
yeah and i think megan kelly might win
they both have the same body yeah i did
her show last week which i never thought
i would do or show but when someone just
asked me i always just say yes that's my
policy oh wow um
and then she did this thing
very nice but when people try to
improvise you know it's it's not easy
she doesn't like it or what happened no
she they didn't do this thing which is
of course this is what she would do but
she's like what does
uh jeff goldblum think of the war in
ukraine so you just sit there and on
just on the fly right like jeff goldblum
monologue about the ukraine that's funny
i mean it's like an impossible
you're supposed to give something they
call it yes ending when you're impressed
oh yeah i'd be like hey i saw you at the
burger place you uh had that giant cat
with you yeah like i've given you
something yes you can he he the cat has
malaria yeah you've added yes and yeah
yeah but you don't you don't ask an
open-ended question
how do i know this the groundlings yeah
i went to work
played socks i went to two classes there
and the teacher was a native american
woman i remember
karen
yeah i had karen yeah mamu
yeah yeah pretty cool man
they're nice but that place because
who's more from the earth than there are
actual groundlings than native americans
and the name ground you think that's all
tied together i wouldn't be shocked i
mean it did i wasn't shocked when i got
there and it's like this is the
groundlings and your teacher's native
americans like it for me it made perfect
sense
i thought
but it was my first experience i feel
like right when you get into hollywood
everybody goes to the grounds yeah it
seems like that's your way on to snl or
something but then you get there and
then they don't even pay these shows are
sold out every night they're sold out
they don't even give you gas money yeah
give me five dollars it's the sold out
theater yeah that's really i don't know
why they don't revolt there they could
tell a judaic at a certain point it
really gets a little like uh
yeah they just take yeah there's not
a taking no giving give a little bit of
gas money i think
what um i was going to open a place next
door called like i wanted to become a
multi-billionaire and just open the
skylings next door and pay everybody
like a hundred thousand dollars a week
and just take all their talent yeah like
what now
dude and if if the skylines if people
air lifted into it
if people came uh there was no parking
you just landed on the roof yet yeah
everyone is a helicopter too it's gonna
be expensive comment well i'm a
billionaire
dude what happened to covid bro
well it's in china now last i heard it
what it's in china now but how can a
disease that is everybody has it or can
get it just be only at certain spots
that's what i don't understand like was
malaria like picky choosy like that
i i honestly have
i'm the worst person i have no
information i don't understand any of it
i don't know
i know there's variance peeled off or
something i had it once i don't know
which one i had i think i had the delta
thing or something wasn't that wasn't
that bad for me but yeah it's just weird
how it disappeared
yeah
and it's funny because in the ninth what
is it 19
i'm doing trump hands in like 1919 or
whatever when they had the other one
terrific
they had that one took like two years it
doesn't matter like how much you have in
terms of technology or what we've gained
knowledge we it still needs two years to
get out of here yeah it seems
yeah it had a great pr run it whatever
it had a great publicist the whole thing
it felt kind of massive but it does feel
i mean it feels like now that it's
complete this it feels way more f like a
lot more of a facade than it really was
if it could just disappear right
well i'm again don't listen to me but i
think what happens is you know it
mutates and it gets weaker as it seems
to get weaker as it mutates and so
that's what happened yeah i know a guy
he was in my house and he died early on
and i it was like right away this is
here and a guy i knew was dead and so i
i immediately was terrified of it oh wow
you know when he was 50 years old he was
an old guy and was he thick was he
smoking was he feeling dope no he was
pretty straight narrow guy and he worked
near like a smoke stack or anything like
was there anything like live far away
from smokestacks he wasn't didn't seem
sickly oh um
he he was he was in that band uh you
know stacy's mom that guy adam
schlesinger yeah and he was in my house
like a couple of months before that and
he was just dead all of a sudden so i
was wiping down my tuna yeah um can a
tuna whatever the grocery store just
wiped it down i was really paranoid
being you never gave you never feared it
i mean i was just at first i didn't
understand it but then once i had
friends that people started dying i was
like
something's going on here but i just
felt like the best course was probably
just to let it run
let it go i don't know if all the seven
it just felt always felt very bizarre to
me and then how you how i could be in
tennessee
and it's
wide open
and you come here and be like oh my god
it's like a slave planet here and then
the numbers weren't that much worse
although i will say i guess when you're
in a city it is going to spread easier
because you're more packed there's yeah
millions millions of people packed
together so i guess that makes kind of
sense it would be more
in the cities but
yeah it didn't seem like it was um
[Music]
no place was really spared really
yeah well it just didn't seem like it
how like how would they let me fly from
one place where people are just right
it's still like that you go a place like
put a mask
all right and then you sit down like you
can take your mask off some airlines you
gotta like like lower your thing to chew
and then put it back up when you're done
chewing and then other airlines are like
we don't give a [ __ ] here at delta or
whatever it is i kind of like that the
up and down that part i kind of like a
little bit you have a little more
privacy on the plane as long as you get
a snack you get it's definitely makes
you feel more like a like a
somebody that's grazing though you know
you're like oh if i get some food then
i'll be fine you know
see here's why i don't like it and this
is like just self-centered stuff yeah i
look worse some people look better with
a mask on but but like this is my mon
this is my money zone this is where i
look really good oh yeah you do have
like kind of like an eff like
lips and everything else kind of falls
apart but this is where i bring it back
yeah you know so i can be like a five or
i don't know what number i am but
no you're not a five bro i think it's
nice to say i'm a five
what you are way more you are
better than a five man i've seen fives
man
and also most people are a five
yeah i feel like i'm um so you're better
than that i i appreciate that but i
think i'm probably pretty average looks
wise it's hard to say i think if you go
for a good run
right
you have maybe a couple you
challenge yourself with some maybe even
a spicy food or something or you know uh
you know i see you eating a steak or
something you're an eight
just by eating
just by whatever ambient if you go for a
good run you show up sweaty you kind of
like that john cusacky sort of i'm funny
you have pretty good clothes like your
good shoes and stuff which i think
brings up a little bit like i i gotta i
think my uh closed game brings me down
with my maybe more nicer stuff it might
help
i think you seem like the guy in like
the beginning of a movie before he's
gonna like get it all together okay i
just downloaded an exercise app this
morning was it fitbot no it was fit
coach oh there's some new ones out
yeah but yeah i got these boots man
these rujo boots and they're nice you
know this is ostrich
is that right yeah
ostrich
yeah
are they bumpy like that oh yeah is that
just what their feathers come out yeah
because the feathers come out and the
crazy thing is i believe that they send
you also the feathers with so it's
almost like a
wait what do you mean you believe didn't
you get them yeah but i did there was
like a separate little package with each
one that i didn't open up but someone
said that there's some company that
sends you the feathers also with the
boots i don't want that
i don't know it's kind of like at least
you're taking it's almost like the guy
that kills the animal and uses it all
you know it's like it just they want you
to like use these feathers
i think if they do that i kind of like
the concept of a company saying okay you
want this leather belt here's also the
hoofs here's the horns here's the you
know what i'm saying like
put a responsibility
on the person
who's going to where okay okay so then
you can say yes i wear leather yeah but
i use the entire animal yes yes you know
i have a wallet made out of a you know
you know duck bladder or goat bladder i
have
you know um
you know i have this little weed
carrying case made out of like a
hollowed out horn or something like i
just feel like then if you did that then
you
they can't trump you by saying oh you
you're wearing that's a that's a really
interesting thought and like a carton of
eggs this comes with beaks yeah like
there's rooms in that carton to just
stuff like that you could stack 12 beaks
right on there four you know i don't
know actually i do know i think
they can have a ton of eggs man so it
could just be one beak
how do you feel about different colored
eggs like do you feel like are one
healthier i feel like that all white
eggs aren't healthy is that just i just
make that up i mean
i will say that in the brown cartons
there's a little more crime if you know
what i'm saying bro i will say that
but i mean i'm just i know this you know
people graffiti a lot of [ __ ] but what
i'm saying is that the uh the white ones
do look a little bit more like they kind
of put them together as opposed to they
were actually hatched if you get that
hatched batch you have bring up hatched
eggs please fresh hatched
right there and there we go
yeah that's
oh yes that's gross yeah if you can look
at
that if you can look at that you can see
uh and sometimes they even have some
green ones
yeah they get they get really funky yeah
it's almost like the colors of tic tacs
that's they're based on um
what percentage of do you think there
was some though like a lot of fear
created by
the media around kobe oh no doubt yeah i
mean
they grab on to something and they just
run it and run it over and over again
just saying something over and over
again yeah uh
is is just it just worms into your brain
you know they have to just go okay we do
this for ten minutes that's what happens
i don't watch the you know i just
stopped watching i think oh yeah people
their ratings are way down
it's horrible yeah i think fox news has
the best ratings i know but i don't know
it's all i mean it's just i don't know i
don't watch it who even goes to their
television like at a certain time to see
so you know what i'm saying like i don't
even think that happens anymore but you
know what did happen was they just found
some alien stuff
um they just declassified a bunch of
aliens is this true i heard that they're
getting people pregnant was that the
thing
it said um i don't know can you bring
that up
i don't believe in aliens really but you
don't well not really because
i just what bothers me is if you're
going to go across the galaxy it's very
large distances okay when you get there
you're just gonna hide i just feel like
you you'd want to be like we're here
you know could you just imagine they're
beings like us i mean they're creatures
of the universe yeah and if you're
traveling this far
okay
why why are you hiding and then what
weird experiments are you doing
right it doesn't seem to add up to a
logical
well i think they used to do the
experiments when they were trying to
figure out what was going on if there
was anything happening here to me i
think it's almost like you ever have
somebody take you to one of those uh
local zoos you know the driving parks a
driving zoo no you ever had that no in
robert louisiana we used to have this
place called um
i think it was larry's zoo or something
larry's
apostrophe s
uh
larry's yeah one larry
but
and they had all types of animals there
you know and they say it's all types but
it's like a mule
and they would like paint you know paint
dew stripes on it or dye its skin you
know to zebra okay but they would have
at least one giraffe they'd have one uh
antelope you know they'd have a couple
animals that were they'd have like a big
big cat or something in a cage and like
keep it far away where you couldn't get
close to it but they would say it was
like a dangerous animal oh would you
they're saying they would paint them so
they would be like other animals
zebra was the only one that ever they
ever did that i went to the circus once
they had a goat and they said they said
come see the the first living unicorn
and this as a from a child they just put
the goats things they kept tying them
together so it's really it was goat two
goat horns they spun together oh wow
over like years we went to one thing in
a middle school and this monkey starts
uh pledging himself it was like a window
and everyone starts laughing and uh
and then he climaxes and everyone goes
ah like that yeah and then and he's
looking you know monk will look you in
the eye he takes it puts it in his mouth
so it went from like haha to uh
to like oh
and then the teacher tried to get
everybody
out of there
when you're in eighth grade that's the
funniest thing you can possibly see and
did he swallow what you think or did
ever at that point everybody was out
you're probably like just locked in yeah
you probably like are now a pin he gave
it a taste yeah he wasn't ah
did it look like it was the first time
he'd done it or did it look like he had
done this is a practice
he looked like a first-time
he saw everyone's reaction to the fact
that he
jizz and then he was like what else he
was just he felt the bug like the
performing bug yeah
he's like charlie that was crazy
yeah
dude that's insane man i remember uh
and i've told this story before and rip
this one fella that i grew up with um
we were in a hot tub right when i was a
child and somebody had a birthday party
yeah
and everybody was excited nobody had a
hot tub
so people are over there and louisiana's
dan you know it's insane the whole state
is a hot tub
so it's insane to get a hot tub it's
like
it's already hot and wet oh well yeah
it's just like you know somebody's doing
a crawfish boil in one part of the yard
and they're literally boiling and then
you're sitting in a hot in a nut it's
just the whole
it's already it's a hot tub of mistake
yeah so anyway we all go over there it's
going to be a sleepover and uh
and there's just one fella who'd been
ejaculating nobody knew
in the hot tub no no oh just on his own
time
and nobody knew it right he nobody he
hadn't said anything and maybe he might
have hung out with older people he was a
rodeo boy
wait i'm confused
he
masturbated on his own time
yep
okay so why is this like why is that
news
is that isn't that generally okay i'm
gonna get there so yeah sorry i was just
setting up i was kind of setting the
table there for that
so what happened next was this so we're
all in the hot tub everybody's you know
kind of just joking around talking about
baseball maybe singing hat you know
ribbing this one fella about his
birthday and that fella ended up dying
years later
but
this one fella named uh cj he's under
the water and he's been pleasuring
himself right and none of us know we've
never even seen it how old are you huh
you're probably 10 maybe and he was
maybe 13 or 14. he'd been held back a
couple times oh god and i remember he
even had a he was he was like he had
shorts on and a belt buckle which was
[ __ ] insane right he was like a real
rodeo boy
well anyway he pulls his wiener out and
he he brings it out of the water like
just like loch ness in it right right
out the water and just starts spraying
into this hot tub and we didn't know
what's going on right
so this one fella named will you know
god bless him man god bless his soul
he grabs on because he didn't know if
something was happening to him like his
body was leaking out of himself like he
was going to scary it was going to keep
going until there was nothing left him
he would put a tourniquet on
yeah yeah like tie it off so he just
grabs it to stop it right and the kid
punched him in the neck
so hard dude that it was just
it was so many immediate things at once
and it was just like well he really
grabbed his [ __ ] to help him he was
saying like let me stop this to save him
yeah it's like if you saw somebody
bleeding or somebody got you know
somebody macheted somebody and you had
to help them and how confusing you're
trying to help when they punch you in
the neck and we oh and none of us knew
what was going on what a crazy like i
don't know was it 13 seconds it was
probably a first thing
it was insane though to just have that
much go on and then you're all just in
this hot water and then there's semen
and there's just oh god
and you don't even know what it is jews
oh we had no idea just touching it like
what is that you got out oh people
didn't know if it was like liquid ghost
or what it was you know
people were shocked bro i remember just
people just like you know mouth open
people like someone guy got he couldn't
even move
was there you had to like tag him like
he got into a game of phrase i didn't
even know like just with like just like
like the shock of it yeah was there
consequences for this 13 year old
pervert
not at that time i'm sure i think that
at that point people were afraid nobody
wanted to rat the guy out so he went
totally un submerged
masturbated submerged and then came oh
no he was just sitting there while
chatting oh so he's like wanking but
he's in there yeah oh my god so he could
have been homosexual as well you know
i'm saying something that's all boys
there but he was also a boy if he was a
man it would have been way weird but
since he was a boy i think it keeps him
out of that that uh
pedophile it's always interesting like
the ages where the government has to cut
off you're gonna you just have to make
an age for
you know laws
but really it's it's a great sweeping
area the whole election
jack off
yeah a week from now you can't you know
yeah but a week ago you couldn't watch
them right i'm wearing kind of a smock
today and i got some real church hair
going on
but i want to let you know that people
don't always realize that physical
symptoms like headaches teeth grinding
and even digestive issues can be
indicators of stress
man i suffered from a lot of that over
the past two years
i'm slowly figuring it out
let's not forget that doom scrolling
sleeping too little sleeping too much
under eating overeating
a lot of issues people face
well
stress
can be cured or at least treated
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to
if you need help with your stress if you
um if you need help with anything just
don't go the road alone try something
and that something can be better help
it's more affordable than in-person
therapy give it a try see if online
therapy can help lower your stress this
podcast is sponsored by betterhelp and
tpw listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
theo that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
t-h-e-o
all right i'm here to tell you guys that
your hair is important if you see people
are losing their hair people losing
their heads you know
if you if ancient times people would
lose their whole head
and now thankfully people are only
losing their hair but
it's still not cool
unless you like not having it
but a lot of men don't like not having
it and that's why there is keeps
keeps
there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
and keeps offers both of them
that's right 24 7 care and support keeps
has a network of expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists
to support you in making your hair goals
a reality treatment start at just 10
bucks per month and they offer generic
versions
of the two fda approved medications as
well
i take these meds and they help me if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash theo to receive your first
month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com theo to get your first
month free keeps.com
theo
yeah i remember we talked about that
last time you're here a little bit about
just like yeah the first time we'd ever
been involved in self-pleasure and just
all that that that went on with that
well you had a good memory
yeah i remember just like
weird stuff happening when you're when
you're
younger in your neighbor you go to sleep
to a neighbor you're just interacting
with another family and you think your
family is normal and then you're like oh
there's this whole
thing going on some people did you ever
like uh
you know like were you ever like
sneaking around anybody's house looking
at people's mom's
underpants or sisters underpants
anything like that like at a birthday
party or something
because that kind of stuff happens a lot
i'm sure i'm trying to think of a
specific story but i'm sure there was
always an interest in women's like
underwear i remember i had under my bed
i i would take out of the magazines like
women underwear ads oh wow i remember my
my
it was suddenly gone right they never
had a talk with me but i think my dad
probably thought i was like gay and then
he was like oh he's probably like
relieved not that he was against gay
people but probably my life wouldn't be
as hard because my mom had me singing
and dancing yeah yeah i remember you you
shared some of that about your mom
just clowns yeah yeah yeah really teach
treating you like a married lady my
sister just like a girl she called me
kylina for like a lot of the time i was
a child
and i was raised as a as a woman
and then um wow really had to come out
as a straight man and it was tough yeah
oh my god at what age
what is you think you do you think there
were people that thought this guy's a
homosexual you know
probably i i no one never really said
but but i would say like i was in the
theater oh here's a story this is
a sign of the times okay a guy came in a
peer educator in high school oh he's
like we're going to get all the groups
together okay so he's like uh i'm going
to run on the chalkboard the different
groups we have at the school you guys
just shout them out okay jocks jocks
great okay he writes jocks on board
um cheerleaders okay you know
uh smoking lounge there's a smoking
lounge group you know oh yeah and then
someone went play gays
he's like okay play games like now they
would never write that on the board but
it said play gays on and i was like the
head i was the president of the drama it
was like the head play game yeah
and then they're like now ask someone
from another group a question yeah and
this girl from like the cheerleader
popular girls goes what do you guys like
do on the weekends
remember that and i was like
oh i did that i don't know what i said
scared just like i was like why
i think i said like we read plays yeah
we try on different willie loman
costumes what's your problem [ __ ] how
do you invite me to a party um i think
yeah if there's somebody that's in drama
and they talk kind of um
if they talk a little weird people will
call them gays probably also being
skinny like i was really tiny
oh and uh tiny did you wear sweaters
i wore sweaters i have even more
turtleneck every now and then oh god
yeah i didn't have any girlfriend in
high school i didn't know why but yeah
you were okay you were gay that's why
yeah i mean you know i was probably it's
okay i think there's probably a half
hour to a couple of to a couple months
where everybody's gay at certain points
of life whether they act on it or not
yeah just like fluid everyone's fluid
well i think the river is just going you
know since you're born here's the thing
that's a true test okay what are you
looking up in your private time like i
have no i've never had an interest to
see like you know sexually a guy's [ __ ]
and like guys it just did not like enter
my
even curiosity like maybe this will do
some i always knew that was just not for
me yeah and yeah same 100 percent i've
never googled
fellow [ __ ] or you know like guy or like
where are you
or brown boners i've never googled you
know
boy boners i've never you know i never
i i tell you this i've watched a ton of
porn i've never even looked at the
wieners in it
yeah it's like that's my wiener
do you know what i mean yeah or it's
just i've never looked at it
i look at it i look at the the entrance
what's that image oh
um yeah i've never looked at that image
before i've never
can you name on one hand or two hands
and this is usually a gay test as well
alrighty how
how many
wieners you've seen in aren't yours
in real life yep
wow so my dad's wiener flash of it
counts
jesus
i mean i must have blocked him out
because i must have seen more than my
dad's wiener
that's like a urinal or something but
never it was never like uh
no one's ever like hear my here's my
dick that's never happened to me yeah
you know like because you're in my face
shower or something i know like uh oh
yeah like when you go to camp and
everyone showers together i saw a bunch
of dicks there oh
just i mean keep going oh damn really
you were looking down
you just go there and just someone's got
a you know in the shower with a penis
those aren't like hard [ __ ] those are
like shriveled shower dicks so passive
dicks yeah how about you what's um
aggressive i just want an aggressive
dick count not like a passive shower
in your life
i remember like
getting like
being under like a blanket or sitting
like in a circle with some other naked
boy when i was a kid just like
i don't know if we were negative bathing
suits on something that just seemed a
little homoerotic
and somebody's penis i think i saw i
know but uh also oh my brother's weaner
i saw oh yeah you know if you have a
brother you're going to see their wiener
i saw my
flash of my brothers too once i don't
even have a real picture of it
dude there was a [ __ ] dude one time
that what came i remember when we were
kids we were waiting my mom used to
deliver all these on newspapers to these
different gas stations right
and uh
this dude came right up by the window
and put his penis against it and while
we're sitting in the car hmm you know
and my brother and i were just like in
the back seat and so we kept fighting to
get like furthest away from it almost
became like a game you know that's a guy
thing to like here's my penis we're
really women like we'll put a vagina
against a window and be like look at
this it's always a guy thing yeah yeah
guys there's something funny about
having something to show people too but
my friend had uh this guy when i was
like 12 he was like
masturbating with a with a
blanket over him and i was talking my
other friend down we're all in the same
room like a magician yeah like a
magician
and my other friend suddenly made his
face because she's like he's like
blank stop cheering up
and i was like don't i'm trying to like
be the you know the peacemaker do you
know the guy's name
yeah yeah i just want to say it yeah can
i guess it that would just give me one
guess which guy you're guessing the guy
upset or the guy who's the guy he's
jerking off okay go ahead
uh
oh is it gonna be tough
rick yep
no
it was john
yeah sure it was okay sorry i messed
your story up going no i think that was
the whole story oh it was
dude i don't like the crazy thing is is
you suddenly have this crazy gun on your
body that like makes
you know like really bad bullets yeah
ineffective fire but it's fun and it's
cool you know
but also there's a lot of shame you're
oh that's pushed upon you totally you
also don't know you know we had a guy
calling recently and said that his
brother taught him how to masturbate and
i thought that there was some value in
that because then it's like a it's
almost like it's almost like tribal like
i'm in a show no no no
you don't feel like no one taught you
did someone teach you i think i'd want
to be taught no a magazine or something
looking at something dirty that's that's
what it is because you find something
hidden
then you look at it then you go hide
whatever caused you to do it so then
you're like
it's this real game of hide and go seek
with people that you know or
your parents or whatever teachers
i just can't imagine now like what they
have at their you know i was saying like
oh bras was
that was it mainly like underwear
pictures did you ever cop in a bra or
something from someone and keep that as
like a momento kind of like you know i
think i had the opportunity i probably
would have i think that that would
interest me
um
fear of getting you know someone
noticing getting caught
were you making love in high school or
anything like that
i could not i i literally was like
so tiny and skinny and i was like the
way i got to girls like i was like a
clown i was clowning and then they would
tell me about the guy they liked and i
just wouldn't have to go home and be
like
fake i was always like secretly in love
with someone that had no idea and i
would listen to like phil collins songs
and get sad damn boy and i was i was
uncle albert and this mary poppins you
know
uncle albert is a humiliating part
you're just
ridiculous it sounds unbelievably and
tough
this girl i was in love with she wrote
me a letter and i was excited about it
and she wrote you make the perfect uncle
albert and i cried so so i realized she
just thinks i'm just like clown oh but
then later we ended up dating like 10
years 15 years later enough dating it is
funny you get those chances years later
you know it's it's really great yeah
it's really great
it's funny how years later those
opportunities that train comes back
around it's a little worn down you know
and the train definitely has a lot of uh
uses a lot of spray tanner
but it comes back through town yeah you
had that were you kind of a popular kid
in uh high school or
i was doing fine yeah i was doing fine
but i think my confidence was so low
really yeah and i had acne too and so i
get so in junior had bad acne okay so
i'd be afraid to even like make certain
letters of the alphabet because pimples
would pop on my face just from the
pressure of it my skin was so tight
because they put me on
retinol or tinactin or something yep so
and i'd put everything on my face i was
so scared you know i was like trying to
use anything we had at the house to get
my skin better
and uh
and i would just be doused up and and so
my skin would be so tight
that if i [ __ ] hit you know oh you
just start bleeding it was that bad it
would just
you know you hit a strong uh
uh you hit a strong constant you know
batch of consonants or something yeah
you know or an alliteration or something
and bam you fire off a
a little uh poor with fight you know you
pop a pimple you're just so scared to
talk somebody because you thought a
pimple was gonna pop and hit him yeah
yeah so then you're kind of talking from
back he just [ __ ] weird [ __ ] you know
all in my head meanwhile other dudes
with pimples are banging and [ __ ]
touching ass and everything we had a uh
retreat to some island
and it was like seventh grade and it all
coupled off and then it was like i was
just with this group of guys that we
just know girls liked us and i just was
like because that's the age where you go
oh girls don't like me like seventh
grade you go oh [ __ ]
you know yeah or like i was in the
mirror at a gap store and it's like the
three-way mirror and i saw like my nose
had just exploded off my face it was
just like see you later and i was like
god damn it and that's where usually
ends up with drugs or i call her usually
say you're standing around a fire
everybody else is coupled off you're
there a couple other [ __ ] ner you
know not nerds but people that aren't
getting no action there that's usually
when somebody picks up a stick [ __ ]
hits
you don't say it like there's some
people start letting their anger out
yeah yeah somebody [ __ ] beat somebody
with a stick somebody starts you know
doing homemade coke like people start
get that's when
once you start realizing you were
rejected
that's when that batch of misfits starts
but you never get away from it let's say
you're really popular in high school you
the pain will eventually hit you you get
older something and like for me you know
it started all didn't hit me i already
got hit when i was younger so it's just
it's not our time but did you have a
chance though was there a chance though
kyle i feel like you had to have a
chance with a woman at some point in
high school and you played it
differently
i could have played it differently yeah
yeah oh i go back in my head like oh
that girl liked me and [ __ ] put it
together yeah i saw boob when i was in i
think uh
10th grade amen in the in the moonlight
it was great i actually hooked up like
i'm kind of underplaying my junior year
i i hooked up a couple didn't have sex
but
it was on things where um were you all
doing oral sex
no this i got yeah i did in night school
get oral sex yeah yeah i did senior year
yeah um
but anyway it was very
hit and miss yeah i've had a girlfriend
a long time now i've gone on dates but
just i've had a girlfriend girlfriend
like three and a half years weren't you
dating some swedish lady spade said
something about that swedish or
something amsterdamian or something
no
we went out with this man's talking
about that
didn't you and schumer used today did
you guys do no that's i really hope that
like i gotta wipe my internet search is
that out there it's like the first
ninety thousand googles of me and no
really never boyfriend or girlfriend
it's almost like it it's like it doesn't
matter what i said that's the internet
this is the truth isn't that crazy yeah
it's like it doesn't even matter what
you say or what's going on whatever the
internet has logged into it okay that's
the power of pr and everything it's like
this is the truth
it's like we have somebody has cornered
the market on the truth yeah yeah that's
what's unbelievable
about these people that own
these websites and stuff it's like
it just feels unbelievable that
they own the power of
of what's true or not anymore and also
mistruth travels six times faster than
the truth in general it's the truth is
usually not as interesting so it's it
and people want click so yeah it's just
set up to send out the wrong information
oh yeah there's no stopping it so that's
just how it is
did you um when you have sex are you
more like the attack dog are you more
like in a do you do it from like more of
like uh
are you more of like a
attack dog that sounds like i can't even
that sounds like
like trouble i don't attack anybody yeah
no i'm not saying that i'm not saying
like you're a predator sorry are you
more of like a like onward are you more
of are you playing like a defensive are
you more like a defensive [ __ ] you
think are we talking like during like
actual sex or like you're an actual sex
man game on whistles blown
i gotta say i i wouldn't say
um
i'm hurting anybody but i would say like
i'm initiate i'm an initiator i'm not
sitting back right yeah yeah yeah okay i
would think that would be a little
feminine to just kind of lie there and
have a woman sort of
the worst i think is if you [ __ ] and
cross your legs at the same time like
this how do you do that i don't know
there's i've definitely seen images of
guys like very passive men you know
frenchmen or whatever it is and they it
just it seems that seems very effeminate
to me in a relationship you know if
you're having sex i think there can be
i've definitely had times where it's
like phone falling in a little bit oh
that's so passive
that's you know yeah yeah are you in a
relationship do you have a girlfriend
right now no dude no i've been in and
out of some dating and it's not all of
it has been a nightmare you know it's
all good i've been dating a lot you do
uh i'm sure you do well i i get like my
dms are like not at all dudes like 99
just really dudes and i go to shows my
shows are like which you know
i'm happy that people come my show but
like it is like
all dudes and like older women really
like women between 20 and and 35 like
do not come to my shows that don't come
we got to get them out there i got a
tour coming up and uh do you i'll tell
you the numbers back of the ratios you
know like youtube will say like your
percentage of watch who watches you yeah
and it just says like 99 dudes on my
youtube thing
what um
you don't so you don't well let's
was megan kelly cool and where did she
tape her show she does a serious xm show
and it's on youtube oh cool and yeah she
was really cool nice to do it uh
yeah
you should do it she's cool yeah i would
like to go
um
is she hot in person is she attractive
well i zoomed in but she's attractive
yeah wow did she feel hot did she feel
flirty at all or no
she brought her husband up like twice
i'd say no oh buzz kill huh yeah and if
you've been married a long time you
think yeah i think yeah
wow
huh she's not saying maybe you're not
doing it no i would still do it but
did you ever uh
did you ever have a job as like a
lifeguard or something i could see you
doing like did you ever try to take a
job that would change the way that women
looked at you like all right i'm gonna
do this i'm gonna do like a you know
boat captain assistant or i'm gonna do
like a
um
you know uh uh
assistant manager or something you know
i mean the theater thing was was like
initially it was like a lot of girl
driven you know oh cause you're gonna go
there to find one yeah they so they stay
up and you dance with them and it's like
you know it's a good mingle
yeah i could see i guess that's true and
i also yeah get getting into like
theater and then also like you're
usually like one of the only straight
men in the group oh if you can sneak in
yeah like when i got to new york and i
started doing that because it was uh
yeah it was slim pickings for the women
i felt bad for them i was like this is
it you know
so did you feel more of a confidence
then but the first day you're like oh my
god a lot of these men are attractive
men but then you start to realize oh
reginald's gay mm-hmm you know allen's
gay right right you know when you're
like jeez he's getting better and better
so suddenly you're damn
rick fox or whatever yeah but i don't
have that any there's no group anymore
there's no i'm not alone i do my show at
my house alone and i do stand up alone
you ruin your show man your show's
unbelievable man everything you do is
like another level of creative it's um
it's really fascinating to watch you
work and to just witness it thank you um
we had a question that came in actually
about uh about your show let's throw one
of these actually see the questions i
had to take this week off it's to do us
get live sketch every week um with very
little help is insane okay here we go
hey what's up kyle and theo uh i was
wondering
i mean i love you guys [ __ ] doing really
really funny stuff up there
but i was wondering kyle what is your
favorite character to do
i mean
they're all surprisingly accurate
but uh yeah i was wondering what your
preference is
all right all right all right yourselves
thank you
i like doing uh alec baldwin right now
yeah alec baldwin
and uh jeff goldblum it's fun
um
how do you do one teach me how to can
you teach me how to do one or is it yes
like people talk in a certain range of
notes you have to have a per like a
relative pitch be able to hear notes
okay so i don't know if you have that
but i need to kind of like be able to
manipulate your your voice box a little
bit okay i think i talk about what a
like a crazy long neck i have like oh
you do freak i went i
hurt my neck and i i had a dream i was
twisting off this top of a coke can on
top and i woke up with my hands around
my neck i was like twisting my neck
anyway i went to the doctor and they
took an x-ray and he was rubbing his
chin looking at my x-ray
thinking i'm like i'm dying you know the
doctor's like
like this and then he calls another guy
in and i'm like what the [ __ ] do i and
he's like and i go what what's wrong
what is that and he goes
you have the neck of a seven foot man
wow yeah but it helps because i can i
can move my voice
so anyway like people have different
people usually speaking like a four to
five note range pretty you know also
pretty gay move by the first one man to
bring another man into the room to look
at him freaking man's neck draw drawing
or something that was actually
homoerotic i feel like it was very
homoerotic yeah it's like hey ron get in
there man you know yeah look what this
guy's got here that almost feels more
like invasive somebody looking at your
x-ray and not asking anything to show it
to somebody else feels very invasive so
much dead silence too all right i'll
teach you how to do jeff goldblum all
right okay uh jeff goldman has a very
large range it's kind of unusual so it's
like you're down here yeah yeah yes yes
yes and he goes what a web here like
that so you go yeah
like that
that's really good yeah
yes yes yes yes yes but
uh jeff uh what's your favorite dinosaur
oh well thank you for asking
i would say
that's really good
i'm not i'm not good man i gotta ask you
why are you paying insane amounts of
money every month for wireless huh why
switching to mint mobile is the easiest
way to save this year
mint mobile
they'll help
they're one of the first company to sell
premium wireless service online only
mint mobile lets you maximize your
savings with plans starting at just 15
bucks a month
for people looking for extra savings
this year
mint mobile
choose the amount of monthly data that's
right for you and stop paying for data
you never use switch to mint mobile get
premium wireless service
that's right to get your new wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month and get
the plan shipped to your door for free
go to mint mobile.com
t-h-e-o that's mint mint mobile
dot com slash theo cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com theo
for most of us learning a second
language in high school wasn't easy or
hell we'd all be speaking a second
language but most people don't know more
than one language no matter what
language they are
ethnicity
that's why babel teaches bite-sized
language lessons that you can actually
use in the real world
it's the language app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions
there's an addictively fun and easy way
to learn a new language and that is
babel
their 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect
app to learn a new language on the go
plus babel's speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and accent
there are so many ways to learn with
babel in additional lessons you can
access podcasts games videos stories and
even live classes plus it comes with a
20 day money back guarantee
start your new language learning journey
today that's right right now save up to
60 off your subscription when you go to
b a b b l el.com theo
that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
t-h-e-o for up to 60 off your
subscription babble language for life
the only one i've ever done has been yes
has been uh morgan freeman
oh yeah you have his timbre and i logan
freeman they said it would take a minute
600 years to get out of this here prison
but andy dufresne did it in less than
20. he crawled through a sludge
i have my voice is close to some people
like bill maher's easy close to my okay
people i'm right in the same range yeah
new rule
uh yeah i saw
i saw him the other night at a party and
he looked oh he's the weirdest looking
guy dude
sorry he's a strange-looking man
some people he has been bothered by me
in just random ways i hear about i was
in whole foods a lady came up to me and
she goes i tell you i was a stewardess
on a private plane with bill maher and i
went up to him i said kyle dunning does
a really good impression of you and his
face dropped and he turned away from me
didn't talk to me and then she was told
to go in the back of the plane and not
talk to him again no
yeah and he was on rogan he brought me
up out of nowhere because that guy does
a terrible you had some guy on it was a
terrible impression of me and then joe
was like no he doesn't play it and then
uh bill goes if you play that i'm
leaving like he really doesn't know and
then aj benza told me [ __ ] but and you
notice he tries to get a lot more like
conservative like loki i think he sees
where the audience is at and so he tries
to you see it over the past year i feel
like yeah you know or but at least he's
brave enough to say stuff that's one
thing about him
i agree with a lot of what he says
yeah and i feel like um but he's
definitely shifting more he's definitely
shifting more i think because he sees
that if there's no
end in the other thing there's no end in
like this let's just keep pointing
fingers at each other and saying
everything is off limits you know yeah
why does that have to be teams can you
answer this question for me because uh
like they why does the democrat
republican why are there two teams i'm
sure there's a reason that i understand
but can we just have a guy and then have
people that like have uh you know issues
issue to issue
i think well we used to have that
what's that what is that that's what
politics you used to just be like
everybody kind of had a guy but you kind
of supported whoever the president was
and then i think i don't know what that
is that kind of changed
it's really interesting i don't know i
don't know if it was just so much of
like the power of social media and the
media like pitting us against each other
with like different clips because that's
what really does it
people see a clip and then they that's
that they latch on to it but even before
the media there was democrat
republicans who were like you're this or
you're that and then like you have
pressure to stay with your team like
there's gonna be any of that it should
be yeah just like
also the way we elect the president
should be i would like to
um change the rules of that
yeah well i think a lot of it's kind of
archaic you know it's old news they're
doing [ __ ] like um
you know 13 original colonies kind of
stuff they need to evolve it a little
bit we should big brother the presidents
uh like
you get people put you like a sort of a
intelligence test then you do like a
psychology test and you do you know yeah
vet them completely all this stuff and
then you put them all together for like
a month and we just watch them survive
and go this guy
brilliant yeah he can handle pressure
that guy yeah that's what we do have
julie chan interview him like once every
two weeks yeah yeah check in i mean to
be a successful politician you have to
you have to lie you have to be
a liar right
yeah but you get to know who people are
when you see them for an extended period
of time you start to be like oh this
guy's like that this guy's like that
and in tough situations i mean same
thing with a bachelor the bachelor
should not be them on vacation it should
be them like having to do their taxes or
like just them in some in a closet for a
while they can't shower late for a
flight or there's only cold water this
week this challenge is you're late for a
flight yeah that's really good there was
this um one of those we almost died
shows you those i shouldn't be alive
oh yeah they're what they are [ __ ]
yeah so they were on the first date
right yeah which is you're trying to be
cool and whatever they get off this
gondola and they're like let's explore
like [ __ ] idiots they're wrong
so they get on the wrong side of the
mountain the gondola leaves without them
they can't find their way back to the
gondola now they're just like trenching
through just vast wilderness okay and
who's leading does it say a man or woman
it's a man trying to be a man okay and
she's there and then she says she wakes
up in the morning she just wants her
breath to be bad you know their their
lives are in danger if you're still tr
you're on this date still oh that's not
true
yeah it's like people get rescued and
like i don't have bad breath and grows
smell like [ __ ] so now they just like
they they finally find this like tent
they run to it like ten maybe there's a
hiker oh and they're just a skeleton
they're like
like a dead guy okay and he's a
experienced climber guy
and he's got a journal and the journal
is like there's no way out of this
there's no i can't get out of this
canyon there's no way out i've tried
blah blah blah and they're like this guy
couldn't get out of here we're gonna die
and by now they're fighting they're not
even with each other no
that's how [ __ ] mad they were and
annoyed because you need each other to
survive they were like go over there i
hate you and that was a tv show this is
a real the show was like documenting
yeah it's one of those like i shouldn't
be alive so now they're dead and they're
just starving and then this guy gets a
brilliant idea what do you think it is
i saves them
saves their lives
what does he do what does he do it's a
man and they're on a mountain and he
saves her life wow she still doesn't
[ __ ] him
unbelievable
somebody saved your life they get a [ __ ]
something what about a hot tub hand job
yeah huh what about busting out from
front of some children
bro i'm saying this bro and this is what
i'm saying what the man does is
i believe that he
he gets them to sing at the top of their
lungs
wow no
no man that's not it at all that's a bad
guess too that's a waste of energy
um
you want to tell you yeah
he
starts
can you guess from there masturbate nope
a
forest fire
[ __ ] brilliant right legend he's like
i'm going to burn it down and just like
start this huge fire and then people
will come all the vegans come right yeah
what's going on
you kill these trees
that's a toughest job being a
firefighter like when these fires happen
and they they have to go in there and
then it can blow your direction you're
just engulfed you're sucking in that
soot all day yeah they drop those guys
out there yeah i have an idea like i i
have a lot of time in my hands you know
they drop the water comes out and kind
of just sprays out
put them all in giant water balloons
then it explodes on the ground is that a
good idea i think it's a great idea or
one giant water balloon that it splashes
on the one instead of a mist because a
mist hits the water that hits the fire
yeah
it's interesting man it's interesting to
see how to to know which one would be
what
you know that's real interesting
brilliant though that guy just started
forest fire yeah and simple and they
probably didn't build it before the
worst part though he probably still
paying for it still paying for that day
in jail god
yeah i guess you gotta you gotta let him
off the hook yeah yeah
do you see um we had a question that
came in let's get back to that question
back to the questions i oh okay here's a
lady
oh there she is beautiful young lady
hi kyle i am
one of your biggest fans i'm seriously
obsessed with you you're amazing um
such a brilliant
comedic mind and um thank you that's
just the flattery portion um but i do
have a question
i'm curious about how you construct your
your sketches because they always feel
these like outlandish concepts but they
never feel
like too cartoonish and i don't know how
you do that with some of these some of
these characters that you create
um
but i'm curious because i do feel like
you have mastered the sort of language
of subtlety in your comedy as well as
being really over the top and i was
curious like how do you know
when the sketch is complete
because i feel like there is an art to
that
and it seems like you are
really good at knowing
sort of how long it needs to be and when
the joke has sort of run its course
um so yeah
thank you there you go
i mean is there any way to answer this
about sounding like a total douchebag
i don't like analyzing your comedy is so
hard to win it is and we can even take
this out if it's not uh oh no that's a
sweet question it's a very sweet
question and uh and she seems very sweet
i am
yeah
uh well i'll tell you that
the one thing i do do which i don't do i
don't think um other people can because
i
shoot so cheaply yeah cause i will like
shoot something and have an idea and
shoot it like raw and like bad and i'll
sleep on it and i'll watch it the next
day and be like oh that's
that doesn't need to be like that and i
have like a fresh thought i also ask if
i'm having trouble with something
um this this uh
helps with a lot of things now is
you sort of like give it to your
subconscious to figure out and go to bed
hmm
i think a lot of uh
you know
cause you you really your ideas kind of
pop into your conscious like yeah it
does come from your subconscious you
know
thoughts
yeah your brain is really a great thing
we forget that yeah and just let it run
i think like trying to
intellectualize things i don't really
get good stuff out of that that's
usually the uh
um
not as uh creative stuff and then in
terms of i edit way down i try to take
anything not needed um sketch takes
uh
a lot of time i think a lot of time like
something would take me like 15 hours or
or when i do the fresh press i do these
like eight minute yeah shorts those take
like over a hundred hours of wow editing
and whatever reworking and you like to
do it all yourself
well yeah i mean i also write with um
my friend john bush and kurt metzger
and um
[Music]
uh you know yeah we we
you know they're all invaluable and then
this girl jessica montez does like kind
of produces it
um so it's it's really a team effort and
um
yeah i uh
cracking like an impression i'll like
take somebody something oh i wanna
during the news i'll try to get them and
there's a certain
um
you know
thing that that you sort of grab onto
and
i can either do it i can't do it
but i can't do women too many women i
just can't get my voice up high enough
you do kardashians
yeah but it's like
like a fake right
and yeah
right it's like yeah babe yeah baby well
he was born biologically no man so true
he's easier to do he's cheating
do you uh is there a what's a celeb you
try to get that you haven't nailed yet
but you're not gonna give up on is there
one
i feel like jeff bezos i could do but i
feel like people really care enough
about him at this point at some point
maybe
um yeah it's hard to know anything i
wouldn't know anything he's said or done
enough you know it's pushed me to do so
many impress doing the show every week
and the instagram before that i pushed
me so
hard to do impressions which
um i'm glad because
you know like
stand up or whatever you're not like
pushed
to work i work all the time yeah this is
like the first few days i took off
because i just was
like tapped out
um
but i i must love it because i work
there's some like weeks i'll just i wake
up at work all day and edit and collapse
i wake up at work all day edit that's
why i don't have a social life
is yeah because of that but um well you
love your work you chose your work as
your as your
as yours as your partner yeah i know i
yeah but it's interesting people kind of
don't realize that sometimes yeah it
does take up it is like like a
relationship almost but the editing i
could do without so much editing that
takes up most of my days yeah
would it be possible to get some but
it's hard to get somebody to acutely do
what you desire and get your real voice
really that's a problem i'm so used to
doing everything like myself that
you know it's hard for an editor to come
in work with the guy now who does a good
job yeah um
but it's hard it's
do you think um well you do a great job
man it's really unprecedented the type
of stuff you do and how creative it is
um
did and just that you're your own tv
show it's unbelievable really i'm
watching your stuff and i'm like this is
unbelievable
because you feel i feel that you're
sitting there doing it i don't feel that
there's like a no there is a go between
fella you know some little henchman or
hinch woman or you know a pen swimmer
that's sitting there you know doing the
strokes for you yeah i keep going like i
can this is my last week i keep wanting
to quit every week
and uh
yeah there's no i don't think there's
anyone's doing a live sketch show on
youtube
and your audience has been growing yeah
it's been growing that's been that kind
of keeps me going that's amazing because
if that stopped i think i would just
have to take a oh take your life bob
but we were we have the number one in
youtube magazine the number one um
uh
i'm making this up youtube mac there's
no youtube magazine well i got a youtube
trading card the other day and i saw
what really yeah there was one of you in
there i think it was
i don't know what it was one of your
characters
you'd like to get youtube trading cards
we also have we have the number one and
the last place live sketch show on
youtube i don't think there's any other
ones
i know y'all were runner up a couple
times
i think it's insane i mean we look at
snl they there's like 30 writers and
they work round the clock
and
it's because sketch is not those those
are the greatest writers sketch writers
in the country and they scour the
country it's just really hard to write
good sketch
i i envy like what you've created
because
you can
you know have an hour of content and
just you know hang out with uh you know
your buddies and stuff and then you do
you build a huge audience yeah well yeah
it's definitely been interesting uh
but i think of the big thing is just
creating something and doing it that's
all it is and it's like you can only
create like i get envious of what you
created man it's just like so
because it feels so creative now like
even two years ago i was like oh this is
so like
you were an early person who came into
corrections everybody said which i
always remember because it really was
true you said who i don't know who this
is for yeah which it still is kind of
like that like
it's got like puppets in it and then oh
yeah you're that girl looking at the
pickle and the ice cream the other day
it's like is this a chill it's like
it's the perfect show because we're all
devolving into children anyway man it's
like it's all becoming we're all stuck
on this mountain look looking for yeah
to start a forest fire we're all on a
bad date with ourselves you know it's
like it's all devolving it feels like so
i just want to keep cranking out the
material and i
i just worry i i worry i'm going to dry
up because uh take breaks
yeah i got a break this week yeah you
have to take it because they you get
punished online before taking breaks
like i've take i took a break like a
couple months ago and it's like i lose
35 of my audience i take three weeks off
like 35 to like spend time to get that
back but otherwise you die man like i
i've struggled in the past years of just
like i did two episodes a week for like
a year two years i think yeah and almost
killed myself yeah like i just had no
things left to even think or say
yeah um
you had a great thing going and your
shows your live shows are
our killer doing yeah are you still on
tour right now we got a new tour coming
up a couple new legs of it anyway so now
i just do it in little legs things i can
manage you know i just need things to be
manageable right now that's the biggest
thing yeah
try to find creative guests right now um
and then trying to get some help i'm
trying to get some help on the producer
front i need to you know it's like i
start to realize i need more help you
know i need more yeah delegating is a
thing where i'm now cause i realize how
to delegate and uh it's hard if you
haven't done it before i'm not good at
it yet i'm trying to get better yeah
um
yeah we just started kind of looking for
some help or trying to figure that out
you know yeah because yeah you think you
can kind of handle things and then
you're like oh i really need to get
some help you don't realize when you're
about to need to go to the hospital it's
like sneaks up on you yeah yeah do an
assistant um
i just started getting somebody to help
me with like kind of day-to-day stuff
that's that's huge like i can't like i
lost like
some bitcoin
oh and you got to find it like that's
stressing me out like have someone else
find that it'll take you a month yeah
and yeah and then you're trying to guess
those 13 keywords
well you know i guess i got stolen i
think i it was in real cash app and i
was sending it to this poker site
that's dirty i don't play a lot but
anyway
i was sending over bitcoin it just
[ __ ] disappeared and i i but they're
both like we don't know and i'm like
okay bye i guess there goes a thousand
dollars
yeah dude i was buying some uh psychedel
uh some um
microdosing capsules because i was
getting off antidepressants and i was
buying some of those online and i got
scammed out oh really 179 yeah some
somebody took me up in snohomish or
somewhere up in washington 179 yeah
yeah you'll recover
hurts still though it does hurt that's
like i don't know a lot of packs things
yeah it just stings when you know
somebody's cheating you
um
have you seen the alpinist man the
alpine uh alpinest alpinest
no climbing movie no i'd like that i
like those is he does he do the thing
without any ropes because that bothers
me
it's so good man how well how high do
you think you could probably climb
i mean it depends on on the
steepness of the
i couldn't climb anything if it was like
straight up we're talking about like a
what we're talking about here how how
can someone climb can you google that oh
you're saying like physically breathe
like 25 000 if you had to climb say
somebody right now is like climb boy
climb you know like
how steep is this what's the mountain is
this you know you're straight up you're
going up a ladder
it's a little like
say ladder just to get the idea what's
it what is the answer here that's the
crazy question
how high can i climb what does that say
there you zoom in on this start dying at
around twenty thousand feet it starts
twenty one thousand feet about three
humans have survived for years at five
nine five oh meters i hate when they do
that okay times that times three okay
we're talking like eighteen thousand
feet yeah
this is the highest reported permanently
tolerable altitude so how high do you
think you could climb this is eight feet
it's about living there like how long i
could climb up there and breathe for a
little while what point when you're
climbing do you start to have that
moment where you look down and your body
stops climbing that's what i want to
know this is the variables involved in
your scenario are are there's a huge
gap i mean there's so many variables
that i need answers to i got this one
then how high do you think you could
climb right
this is a good one okay
actually let's finish this one then i
got a good one okay
or i'll just do you think you could
climb say you had a jingle bell right
hanging from a little rope off your chin
okay
how high do you think you could climb
without it ringing at all
like okay is it really tied tight is it
swinging is it breezy out like it's not
breezy there's no wind zero wind there's
a i would say there is
three quarters of an inch of thread okay
is it a rocky terrain is no you're just
on a ladder
a ladder you're a st a steel ladder
i don't i would say maybe like a mile
like if i get a mile up
without making it ring
no dude i don't think it would ring wow
that's what were you saying thanks dude
what were you thinking i thought 20 feet
no
you know how slow you would have to go
to not get the thing you don't got to go
smoothly you got to go smooth
that's what you're you're like
jingle dude one thought look how fast
i'm not even moving
my head you just gotta move your limbs
quickly
would you be scared you would hit your
head on one of the rungs and that would
ring it would you climb with your face
out to the side i'd probably bring it
back a little up tuck the chin
i got a i got a thing like uh that would
really blow your mind i'd put the bell
in my mouth
if it's like dangling a couple inches
i'm going all the way but then you have
one little breathing mishap or this or
that and you're running that whistle
yeah
i used to boulder climb which i would
like to get back to
no but you should get out there i could
see a lot of women being out there for
you i don't talk to people in public
anyone who shows i leave right after i
just feel like really i just feel really
uncomfortable just going to a stranger
it's just weird to go up to a stranger
it's weird but that's all getting
married is is just going up to a
stranger that's why i'm not married i
don't think you've known for a while
yeah well no i think the best way is
you're working with a person so we're
not in an office you know yeah
theo you and jane work on that report
and then you wrote the report and you're
like oh this rapport then you rag on the
boss and you guys laugh and you rag on
the other guy in the office and then you
then you hook up one night and you've
known each other for six months and
that's good yeah then you get married
yeah not this nonsense we do
and then also they've seen you perform
that's a weird yeah
have you sent ever sent like a dm to a
celebrity or just to a woman dm'd i've
dm'd but
i don't think out of the blue like hey i
saw your pictures i've never done that
yeah um i've done like hey i saw you
somewhere
like there's a lie you'll say that no i
then i really did see him oh okay yeah
but they didn't write back oh maybe i
didn't see it i saw it you're a catch
dude you got all you got everything
going for you
i really think that that's nice you man
i think you have one of us isn't a
[ __ ] woman dude dude we'd be [ __ ]
dude are you kidding me dude we'll be in
a relationship
right here dog you'd meet my mom dude
yeah dude she'd tie little strings
around me and keep me in a room like
this love you
um
dude i get so worried about just where
the world's heading are you worried
about it
um
yes and no i feel like i've had such a
good run i'm kind of like okay
do you know what i mean right but i'm
talking about the next gen next two gens
yeah like i i feel bad but i kind of
don't care about i kind of don't care
i probably if i thought about it but i
don't think about it at all
i mean it's funny how the news puts
something in front of you to care about
every night there's a billion children
that go to
who have been
hungry yeah you know but then we decided
like this is a march for this or this
now the ukraine thing all very important
stuff but it's like there's always
there's never a march for starving
children there's never there's always
some horrible things happening it kind
of numbs you out like what are we doing
what is cnn telling me i need to be
worried about today because
there's horror everywhere which is the
horror we're going to focus on now
it was like you know black lives matter
while then when it went to covet now
it's on ukraine and it's like okay
there's gonna be a next thing people are
getting burnt out of it i think do you
think that ukraine or covet all of the
whole thing like hey this news fear the
value of getting all this information
is
we don't care but at the same time we
are addicted to it i know so that's the
tough part well that's the thing where
people you get on a team you feel is
part of your identity you're like you
know you know i'm part of this cause
which is good you know it's all like
good stuff to help uh
problems but just like the number one
cause every day be like they're starving
children dying right like that should be
our number one top story and then we'll
go okay this other thing but we're you
know that's not how it is yeah okay
and i wonder like people don't even care
about things like santa that much or
anything no one cares about santa
anymore nobody talks about him isn't
that crazy yeah like he's mad he comes
he's everyone presents
yeah
are you worried about the future yes i
would assume since you asked that
question you're worried about it yeah
i guess i am i'm just worried about
it used to feel really neat to be human
and i don't know
[Music]
if we as a society
value it enough more than the people inc
or the people in control value it enough
as much as they value like power and
money well and so they're willing to
sacrifice everything
they're willing to let it really whittle
away
you know i think the underlying problem
to all that is
is we don't
face death
it doesn't it sounds incongruous it
doesn't seem like that
tracks
but
the fact that we
are the first species where we know
we're gonna die like of course you have
to put that species on medication if you
just went to another planet like here's
a speech they just found out
they'd have to be very religious and
it's just too psychologically upsetting
and then you you have this energy you
you're pushing that down you got to
focus on something else like we do
cultures like ours that
idolize celebrity are
generally the most unhappy
yeah and it's generally the most they
most push away death i mean those two
things are equally correlated there's
other cultures that they bring the dead
out and it's a whole thing for a long
time yeah and they're they're less
stressed out in general and they don't
like understand you know celebrity as
much or revere it it's kind of like an
immortal thing when you think about
celebrity it's like this way of like see
we live forever
everything's so incredibly temporary
yeah we don't really we don't really tap
into the reality of it we create this
kind of pseudo-reality that
of life through celebrity or like of
longevity through celebrities that what
you're saying yeah and i i i'm kind of
torn because it's also like yeah we
should distract ourselves it's such a
i i i don't know go back and forth yeah
really you're on a roller coaster and
then you're like told the end is a brick
wall and you don't know when it's going
to come and have and enjoy yourself yeah
that's like that's kind of where we're
having to deal with and so we're on
pills
yeah
and watch
do you think that um
oh i was gonna ask you this oh this is
what i thought about aliens visiting the
place oh right right i thought that
aliens just come by it's almost like
when your mom's like i'm gonna take you
to the um
i'm gonna take you to the
the local zoo or whatever you know yeah
and alien kids are like [ __ ] mom i don't
want to go to that dump you know and
it's like some sometimes there's still
people going over to see earth it's like
they're so advanced but every now and
then like some shitty family brings
their kids over like oh well look you
know mars is full you know they got a
line over at neptune you know dad
couldn't get tickets to saturn so we're
going to run them over here way better
than those right i agree but i think in
in in any other world
solar systems right they want to go
though so they're like oh [ __ ] mom we
got the old goal that we go to earth and
we drive all the way there
the parents are like our fly you know
when they're in their flying dry you
know driver and then they get there and
like oh [ __ ] mom this place sucks you
know so they don't even land anymore
bother to land okay they don't even land
anymore they're just like oh [ __ ] this
guy
this guy's over here jerking off and
tasting it at the
yeah this guy doesn't you know this guy
hates santa like maybe it's all like
this guy over here is uncle albert like
mom this place is a [ __ ]
jump you know we got to get the f out of
here mom i was like all right we'll
leave let me at least burn this lady's
womb over here just to [ __ ] let him
know we were here
and then they send out one little torch
flame and they jet
i've seen the tic tac videos and the and
i don't know what it is and i definitely
know i don't have all the answers here's
what i think it is okay i think it's a
multi-dimensional thing things popping
in my guess
not like people visiting because it's
just so far away right that it and then
not to contact it seems like more of
like an anomaly because you know there
there's
a lot of
evidence that there's like a
multi-dimensions right like yeah i don't
know where gravity there's a lot of
gravity missing that they're like maybe
that's folded into dimensions or
something yeah i don't know anything
about this but i'm just gonna
believe it no man look i think you're
really really smart man um
[Music]
lucia's big yo guns were aliens trying
to reach earth
scientists make message to send earth's
location to aliens ignoring stephen
hawking's warning
okay let's zoom in on that on the uh
yeah there's that tic tac video that's
crazy i i saw when i was a kid a ufo um
just like that
way high in there two like tic-tac-y
things that were making no noise and
they were engaged each other i don't
know what it was it was look that kind
of thing probably but wow i know it is
but i wouldn't say
i don't i just i don't know and this
here's a science of design a radio
message to be beamed in a deep space
that reveals earth's location
uh yeah that might be a bad idea yeah
and that's yeah and somebody's gonna
sponsor it or something too it'll be
like oh this is brought to you by weiner
schnitzel you know yeah
this is horrible somebody's gonna hear
him be like [ __ ] wiener we sent out that
one thing remember a year i think it's
on voyager yeah we would say like record
that gold record remember that and it's
got it's embarrassing now like the the
[ __ ] we sent out was not horrible like
bad music every five years they send
this [ __ ] out it's bad yeah that had
nelly on it it had nelly on it i think
changi was on it every five years they
sent out something horrible it was like
the dukes of hazzard show or something
little boys yeah it was a couple of
early episodes of uh just the ten of us
no it was no it was small wonder that
girl was a robot they sent out i was
like here's the tv shows we we do
dude melissa joan hart came to one of my
shows dude i met her once
was she i i think i got to meet her
afterwards i don't remember outside but
she seemed really sweet
i met um
[Music]
paris jackson last night she was really
nice dude i met her she's so sweet yeah
um
yeah melissa joan hart you big fan of
the witch movie i mean i just remember i
was just it was just neat that she came
you know yeah that she came out she's a
fan big fan yes she loves a lot of
comedy mm-hmm and she came out man she
came out and uh it was in nashville i
she lives in a hometown that i grew up
in and i go oh i love that sherwood
diner and she said i got food poisoning
there and barfed in their bathroom oh
yeah
dude i remember um
[Music]
oh let's bring up that that alien
article real quick i want to go through
that deal
all righty then ufos left radiation
burns and unaccounted for pregnancies
that is this is what i heard recently
now
this seems dumb because can't you just
like do the dna test and know it's not
human
encounters with ufos of reported enough
americans suffering from radiation burns
brain and nervous system damage and even
unaccounted for pregnancy that's the
part that some chicks are just tacking
on just to
get out of i think probably
interracial relationships and [ __ ]
it just seems like a very easy thing to
uh figure out and if you're telling your
dad
me yeah
figure that out yeah if you get 23
and me back and it has like a you know
yeah like sector five
zuckerberg one
i'm eight percent zuckerberg one the
database includes more than 1500 pages
ufo related material i am
do you believe they ever found something
and hit it that's i'm just going to ask
you a point blank i don't want to beat
around the bush anymore all right
no i don't i think they found some uh
military like advanced stuff but i don't
know i would say but this is a guess i
don't know
i i just don't think it's likely
that
a spacecraft made of material flew
you know
at least
four and a half light years closest
solar system
we're not getting any radio signals from
that we're not getting any radio signals
from anything in our view okay so it has
to travel
hundreds of light years which
i mean you take you shoot a a light at
the or laser at the moon it takes
like a second and second and a half to
get there right it took us i don't know
like a week to get there going 18 000
miles an hour yeah now for
100 years go that fast
and then you finally get to and you
can't even go that fast because your
mass will be infinite so you have to go
close to it that's why i think it damn
jumping through wormholes or something
else right okay so you're saying there's
some uh
the distance if you really get a
tectonic synthetic going on exactly
there's some interstellar tectonics
interstellar tectonics you're a smart
guy man um
i wonder if we covered everything was
there any other good question that came
in for kyle
any other real ripper you wanted to get
to
okay i'll answer any question
pull up one more for him huh
let's get one more
oh this guy's got a good hair game
yeah here we go
yo theo gang gang
yo baby thanks for the message wanted to
ask your guest um if
the election were today
would you vote for
trump considering
that he's talking about running again or
biden
if
he were to actually survive this
presidency
or do you have someone
else
that you would rather lampoon
um
yeah that's my question
man could you imagine if trump and biden
went
head-to-head again could you even
what it would even be like at that point
it's all turning into a strange show
yeah right it's a very real question
will he live i mean i've never been more
concerned about a health of a president
unbelievable he doesn't even seem like a
well grandfather yeah he'd be worried
about grandpa
like i've had grandfathers that seem
kind of well you know like he doesn't
seem that like yeah right now yeah
mine does not seem well
so if but what are they going to do not
have him run again that's what they
would do probably and then i've never
heard the president a president make
this sound
during a speech
what if biden dies off will you have a
funeral for you the character what will
you do
maybe i'll do ghost biden i don't know i
just pulled that out
[Music]
i like it i don't know how do you do
biting can you shoot me real fast come
on man it's like hey he's got a fuse
you've got like a little thing here is
it come on man hi mcmahon do it come on
man come on man
come on man look look look look at that
you're trying to get
not not not the thing the thing man come
on come on the guy
come on come on guy the thing hey
the guy without the shirt he got
this he's a bad dude man he's a bad dude
he's a bad dude man he's maybe i think
an audience can guess whether i'm doing
i'm going or you're going okay don't
tell them all right come on man he's a
bad dude
come on man he's a bad dude
this one you'd maybe not underneath the
video they could write
all right let's try it one more time all
right yeah okay
hey what are you doing over there guys
come on man
it's over the the jew crit and not not
not the jew crane the other other thing
okay put your comments below
yeah what do you think who was who don't
cheat
cover the screen from the beginning now
we're telling them all the rules and
posts yeah
that'll be laid out
kyle dunnigan man one of the most
entertaining minds in the world and this
guy's on the wife hunt too i want to put
it out there for i don't think i think
it's done like i can't imagine that
you don't want a family no i do but i
don't know how like i'm not social i
don't know how this
uh would even you know you see a movie
like you're in the store and you bump
into someone and your cottage cheese
falls you start giggling and picking it
up and you're like what's your name like
that's i think that could maybe happen
it seems like a long shot do you eat
cottage cheese uh no but i also think uh
i'm probably a uh i must be an odd
person today it must be odd
no i'm sure you're good just putting on
wigs all day
i bet some woman is gonna absolutely
someone's into that okay
do you um
would you do you do like a horseback
riding do you do a good date what do you
do do you do you know i go all out i i
think i do i think i am a good date you
know i i listen and i like to plan some
i'll pay you know that's that's a plus
right there when a guy pays that's huge
um
but i've had some very weird days i was
on a date with girl and we're at this
restaurant she's on her phone the whole
time i took a picture of her on her
phone and i texted it to her i thought
that'd be funny you know you got a text
of yourself on the phone and then you'd
go like oh sorry
but she goes oh i do look cute she
thought i was saying like you're cute
and i was like get out of here
wow
i had another anyway i'm going up yeah
it's fine i went on yeah it's it's tough
man it's tough figuring out
what to do with your
it's tough figuring out as you get older
too it gets a little bit tougher too
it doesn't get set in your ways
exactly i've not lived with someone in a
long time
but um
i can't complain everything is good and
i also sometimes i'm like boy i'm glad
there isn't like screaming children here
right now a lot of times i'd see my
friends sometimes like dude dude you're
so
shitty diaper what do you mean
was that fighting yeah oh nice dude nice
dude
nice dude
thanks man um
well kyle dunnon you guys can check out
his show it comes out when it wants to
come out uh but it's got a great channel
on youtube also i'm doing a tour right
now so okay if people go to tour at
kyledungan.com come see me i'm on the
west coast tempe arizona too oh
beautiful
we'll put that in i have a lot of
friends that have gone to see you and
enjoyed it i love it getting back out
there
what's your show like is it just stand
up all over the place no like i'll play
the piano i do like i i actually project
onto the screen the the impressions and
stuff okay yeah i'm trying to bring a
bunch of different stuff to it so it's a
real full throttle huh yeah kind of the
show i do on youtube kind of starting to
do that because that's what people want
to see usually come to see me now will
uh want to see impressions and what
about kirk is he out there kirk does
stand up yeah he's out and about any
other characters can hit the road with
you
uh i'll zoom jessica and kirp in and
john in
beautiful that's great
kyle done again man dude you're so good
to get to spend time with you man and
thank you so much for having me laugh
especially through all the freaking the
the weird world as we wait for aliens to
come and pick us up you too you too
how great that we can hang out and laugh
i don't know how we i got into this
business or whatever i don't remember
deciding to do it but i know it wasn't
so psyched like i'd be so bad in an
office would you i did it for years and
i got fired i got fired all the time
like kyle
i worked for this she does the taxes for
the rockefellers all i had to do was do
take a long time
yeah i just had to do copying and she
brought me to the office and she goes
you do terrible work and i was just a
copy boy and i was like
24.
dude i remember actually i used to mail
forms my job was mailing forms right
form mailer right
and i did a bunch of mushrooms or lsd
one time and went in there right this is
insane bro and it was my girlfriend's
mom this was in high school
i got stripped down got completely naked
right okay
well that's not even half of it
so i walk out of the work
i walk out of the workplace the second
that two women see me naked walking
out of the workplace i'm fired
immediately right so
but i'm so [ __ ] up i didn't know got
into my car 84 ford escort with a
missing passenger seat somebody stole it
and i get home anyway finished the drugs
wear off blah blah blah lose my job but
here's the crazy part a week later
one of our company one of our associate
companies in new mexico got all my
clothes in a box how crazy is that did
you mail them yeah
that is an insane story did you you knew
you were naked at your office
or you didn't know you were so high you
know you were naked when i do heavy
drugs i get real native americans so i
go back to the river you know yeah i get
back to like we don't need this
we don't need this common thread of you
know this brit this [ __ ] this british
guard we don't need to see your story
though like you deserve to be fired like
that's cool and you were like i was
trying really hard to make copies and i
got fired you you were having a good
time
i mean
i don't know what i was doing man but we
were both
somehow inadvertently though we didn't
know it looking for something different
yeah there was a part of us that was
like i'm going to [ __ ] this up i think
so i think i was like no i'm never going
to do i can't do this so this compadre
ends up at the right bowl of waka yeah
oh guacamole yeah i also look up just
i'm sure you too like just lucky things
happened i mean maybe unlucky things
happen too you wouldn't even know but
did you ever have a pregnancy scare out
there once you did get active and
fertile
no
i mean i've had like condoms break where
that and then like morning after pill or
something like that but i never was like
a girl was like i'm late that's never
happened to me did you ever have a uh
a thing where i'm pretty protective are
you myself you wear a lot of condoms huh
um
really
unless i'm like in a relationship for a
while or like
i've done std tests with the
ladies and uh
that's another way to go but
if i don't know him
have you just ever winged it
in what manner in a sexual manner with a
woman and just said i'm just gonna
assume this woman doesn't have an std
and i'm not gonna use a protection i
i've put i've put it in
when i shouldn't but i've gotten tests
after and i i have been i've [ __ ] out
wouldn't it be crazy for somebody who
could put their penis inside of a woman
and then guess or not if that an std and
get it right every time
the that would be such a waste of an
amazing talent it'd be a waste really
why wouldn't how could you would you go
on the road with that and make money how
do you monetize that bring stephanie up
here you just pick people out of the
crowd
yeah you have herpes
you got yeah
i don't know be something man i'm just
saying there's a way out there for
everybody to make it's a way to make
money yeah absolutely so stay alive
folks don't give up on yourself no do
not have a good time let's have a good
time yeah in the moment they say that
stay in the moment babe it's all that
you have that's all all right we'll see
you guys next time peace
i'm just floating on the breeze and i
feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
[Music]
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it
in my bones
but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
just
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
hands
[Music]
built